i used to feel
so much peace staring into the heavens
until a piece of it fell raven-haired
kibana treks through a desert
an asteroid strikes the earth behind her
unleashing a sandstorm
she emerges from the dust unscathed then
she marches through an apocalyptic war
zone
and the nightmare began soldiers stuck
behind crashed cars shooting firearms
a helicopter flies toward the golden
gate bridge
we thought it could be contained at
headquarters ash commands an extraction
team
but it evolved so
we did too one of our own is m.i.a
i need an extraction team now uniformed
operators rush to gear up
if there's a way to stop them
you will find it meanwhile havana is
trapped in an alien sprawl pinned
against a tree-like organism
but i know black goo engulfs her
you will find me
first words appear tom clancy's rainbow
six presents in a chopper above san
francisco lion nomad and ella discuss
secure exit i'll take out the nests and
i'll find him
he wears a full face helmet i have a
signal let's go the chopper hovers above
a building in an alien parasite
containment zone the trio descends from
ropes they are already out of the nest
they point their guns they open fire at
humanoid single-celled organisms that
shoot spikes from their skin
lion defeats two arcanes using a table
as a shield
ella throws a bomb releasing a sonic
wave that debilitates the alien parasite
he punches an arcane with his weapon
then kills into the headshot an arcane
with a bulbous back leaps at ella but
nomad shoots the breacher dead
it explodes showering them with black
goo and spikes which they narrowly avoid
clear let's move out lion separates from
his comrades as they advance through the
abandoned building
he deploys a small recon drone to scout
ahead
clock's ticking he uses a tablet to see
from the drone's perspective
i found her he kicks up in metal doors
and spots hibana
he races toward the oozing tree
imprisoning her peels her off and drags
her to freedom
shape-shifting tormentors spawned from
goo on the ground and launched spikes
he opens fire then calls for backup
a bomb breaks through a wall and his
allies slay the tormentors with skilled
shots
he carries hibana on his back as ella
plants a device it detonates
electrocuting newly spawned tormentors
check for the exit between them and the
exit and apex spawns
it has gaping holes for eyes and a mouth
and tentacles for legs
more archaeans appear launching their
bodily weapons
a breacher pounces knocking ella down it
slices at her with sharp claws
she kicks it away but it pounces again
nomad aims her gun
not so fast she strikes it with one shot
and ella shucks a grenade
it explodes the breacher which releases
spikes that strike the apex as it bursts
into flames
the screen glows yellow
later hibana slowly opens her eyes her
comrades stare at her as they fly past
the golden gate bridge
hey you all throwing me a party
yeah do you budget me stole the
fireworks
team it's ash we're not done yet vip
down
tom clancy's rainbow six extraction a
ubisoft original
september 16th